quiero preguntarle primero cómo vivió
usted los momentos de angustia y cómo
logró salir ileso
bueno primero que nada muchas gracias
por el espacio sí fue un momento de
mucha incertidumbre
no sólo porque estaba yo como individual
sino que habían también familias habían
niños habían mujeres y cuando vemos que
la escalada de violencia había alcanzado
un punto de no retorno la realidad es de
que aún no trato de actuar con el mayor
instinto de supervivencia posible pero
creo que dependiendo de la persona que
le llegues a preguntar sea la historia
que tuvo para poder salir salir con vida
y quizás pues también con historias no
tan afortunadas sé por medio
sobre eso le quería preguntar porque
vivimos a través de las redes sociales
imágenes de una violencia que fue
extrema sin embargo y pese a los
primeros reportes en redes al día de hoy
no se habla de fallecidos solamente se
está hablando de heridos usted que sabe
de las cifras que se están manejando
plena certeza creo que nadie tendrá lo
que si posa de ver es que cuando estaba
ya saliendo y logrando escapar de estos
no aficionados y nuevo medidas y si
puede ver personas que ya estaban como
seguramente en muchos vídeos en imágenes
tristemente se ha visto personas que ya
estaban con un modo desarticulado de
tener su cuerpo ensangrentado sin
respirar dudando mucho que minutos
después lo sintió incluso de segundos
hoy han sido sido atendidos me parece
inverosímil
más allá de la interpretación yo no soy
médico que esto me haya arrojado ninguna
cifra de fatalidades claro es que en
este momento se habla de aproximadamente
26 heridos con tres personas en estado
crítico cuando el sábado los primeros
reportes hablaban de 27 personas
fallecidas así que pues ésta es
información que tendrá que aclararse con
el paso del tiempo y ojalá muy
rápidamente usted sabe ya que está allí
tan cerca de los hechos en que van las
investigaciones que les dicen a ustedes
sí sí la realidad es de que se habla de
que el propio domingo se abrió lo que
llaman una carpeta de investigación para
encontrar detenidos
la realidad desde que nos hemos visto
que haya un avance de franco y
obviamente las aficiones la inclusión de
las propias redes han identificado los
perfiles de los de los ataca de varios
de los atacantes y sin embargo al día de
hoy no hay un solo detenido quizás a
esta hora ésta no estaba comenzando el
partido de fútbol una hora más tarde
estaba haciendo esta masacre
y que no existan detenidos después de
haber tantas cientos de imágenes y
momentos tan cruento esposa creo que
habla un poco más de la de la autoridad
competente en q para hacer esta esta
investigación
mire la batalla campal entre los hinchas
del querétaro y del atlas es un episodio
más de una violencia que no es
infrecuente en los estadios
latinoamericanos como se llevó a esta
gravedad y usted como hincha que medidas
cree que se necesitan para proteger a
los fanáticos del fútbol y al deporte
sí sí la realidad es de qué bueno si
bien ya entre el equipo querétaro y
atlas ya existió algún tipo de rivalidad
remontarnos al 2007 cuando hubo un tema
de que el querétaro tiene que ganar un
partido para no descender y ese partido
era en la cancha de atlas descendieron
de ahí se genera una rivalidad 2018 un
episodio bastante parecido claramente
sin alcanzar estas escalas y demás la
violencia que creo que el problema de
fondo fue la por un lado el roque
proceso del salvajismo de estas personas
que eso tiene un trasfondo social
bastante bastante fuerte pero al final
de cuentas creo que hay una
responsabilidad grandísima y una
flagrancia de las autoridades que no
pusieron medidas de seguridad
suficientes yo al ingresar dentro de la
zona visitante tenía el filtro de
seguridad en el cual revisaban inclusive
que no tuvieras algo en la suela de los
zapatos
ingresas al estadio y no habían y no
habían siquiera figuras estatales de
policías sólo había un par de personas
inclusive yo solo llegué a ver a dos
señoras entre 40 y 50 años resguardando
a la porra visitante ya luego si ves que
en el segundo
los estos vándalos intentan salirse de
la zona local me refiero a los hinchas
de querétaro y que la propia policía les
abre las puertas y que no sólo eso la
policía no defiende a los del atlas hay
imágenes incluso en que hasta nosotros
nos golpean entonces creo que hay una
responsabilidad bastante compartida al
respecto